a mis espaldas una antigua edificio de
viviendas de lujo se trata de la
anterior rones Sanz villared un edificio
con capacidad para 600 personas que era
de lo más lujoso de la ciudad de este
edificio se derrumbó por entero en el
terremoto de la pasada madrugada del
pasado lunes matando a todas las
personas que vivía en su interior el
constructor de este edificio a sabiendas
que presuntamente no había seguido las
normas necesarias de seguridad en contra
de terremotos intentó escapar de Turquía
después de que montarse un avión en
dirección a Estambul en Estambul sacó
dinero de varios cajeros automáticos
para llevárselo a Montenegro Donde había
comprado en billetes sin embargo la
policía turca lo detuvo antes de que se
montase en ese avión en dirección al
país balcánico como a este señor la
policía turca ha detenido en las últimas
horas y días a unas 12 personas acusadas
de haberse saltado la legislación turca
de construcción y de seguridad para
edificios muchos consideran sin embargo
esta legislación ha sido desatada por
todo el mundo en la región sobre todo en
todo el país miles de edificios cientos
de miles de edificios incluso no siguen
esta regulaciones de hecho en 2019
presidente ahí erdogan firmó una
amnistía para los propietarios de estos
pisos que no seguían las regulaciones a
los que se permitió sin pagar las multas
que les tocaba seguir manteniendo sus
pisos uno de los motivos según muchos
expertos por los cuales la cifra de
muertos en ese terremoto en el sureste
de Turquía y el noroeste de Siria ha
sido tan alta